these are sugar-free aquito sugar
cookies
they're not cute they're knocking though
hey gq i'm meghan trainor we're gonna
switch it up a little bit today because
i'm gonna talk about
the 10 essentials i need for the
holidays
this is essential this is my
very first holiday album a very trainer
christmas and it reflects i don't know
if you can see this but it's reflective
how cute and it's very special to me
because my whole family's involved
and we even have a family photo my
birthday is december 22nd
so i am a christmas baby i've always
been obsessed with
the holidays my wedding was on my
birthday as well and it was a whole
christmas theme
so i knew my entire life that this would
be made and that i
loved writing christmas songs i wrote a
christmas song with john legend off of
his last album
called bring me love we always joke and
laugh and talk about how we're gonna do
a christmas album
and we thought this year was the
toughest year so we should bring as much
joy as we possibly can for the holidays
and we did it
some of my favorite songs off this cute
little album it's a big album it's 18
songs the most i've ever had ever on an
album so
so cool i love my song with earth one
and fire
called holidays i have a very special
cover
of have yourself a merry little
christmas with my father gary trainor
he plays the piano seth macfarlane is
singing white christmas with me
and then i even have my little cousins
singing rudolph the red-nosed reindeer
i hope it brings a smile to your face
because this year was tough
moving on to the next thank you mama how
gorgeous is this
this is my favorite christmas candle
this year i get a new one every year
and it smells like apple cinnamon
christmas heaven
i'm obsessed with online shopping so i
have a problem i got this like it's like
a centerpiece but a candle holder
it was destiny because this candle fits
in here perfectly and i can finally see
the name you guys gotta get this candle
apple honey butter by dw
so good it fills the entire room with
christmas love
okay we have a new tradition usually we
buy these but
we're better this year we made these my
mother made these
they're sugar cookies i need sugar
cookies
also i'm pregnant so my craving
everyone's like what's your craving i'm
usually salty but this year i'm sweet
i need sweet and i need to also be
safe for my babies okay there's flour in
them
but whatever they're healthier than
other sugar cookies at the store
okay so we're doing our part the
frosting is definitely sugar-free
i could crush like i'm being responsible
i'll crush four i'll spread them out
throughout the day
breakfast lunch snack snack dinner
dessert
and my mom tried to make them red for us
they look so good mom thank you so much
my next essential that i must have which
is the best one of the best things about
the holidays ugly christmas sweaters but
in my opinion
i'm adorable there's nothing like ugly
about these so i feel like we should
change it up
instead of ugly sweaters should be like
funky sweater or like
i don't know i don't have a good name
yet but because i'm pregnant
i'm growing so fast and um
it's been so excellent because i can't
fit in all my clothes anymore so
i've told them for all this promo i want
to wear big
oversized goofy lovable holiday sweaters
so this promo has been fabulous for me
these are so essential
in life all year round uggs christmas
holiday
gorgeous velvet red uggs what is this
dark red moody red
burgundy oh i've had these for like five
years now i love them so much i wear
them all year long
and they're so cute this would go so
well with this outfit i'm wearing right
now
every photo shoot we do or video shoot
the main thing that's in
the bag for the car ride is where are
the uggs
and my mom always makes sure we have
extra uggs because i'll jump from my
heels
immediately into my uggs fun fact on my
music video with earth wind and fire
i was in heels for like two shots and
then i wore
red uggs the whole day dancing with them
on stage
they didn't even comment about them i
was like isn't this impressive
the next essential and the other awesome
thing about holidays
is you can wear whatever you want look
at these look at this jewelry
these are bows they're so cute and you
can get them
everywhere to be safe this year let's
get them online
but look at that pop look at the green
pop this is the time to wear
goofy big fun stuff and no one can say
anything
who cares what others think this is
actually what i'll probably wear for
christmas day
another essential we love decorating our
tree
we've had this tree up since october i
got all new ornaments this year because
this i have to be bigger and badder and
better than ever because we're doing our
holiday album and i ordered all these
ornaments and the first one that came
in i'm not even lying was this one
and i know my baby's not here yet but i
couldn't help myself it's so cute baby's
first christmas
is so cute he's gonna be large in my
stomach
on christmas day he won't be there yet
but like he's there you know we're all
like he's here
everyone's gonna be touching my belly
tested and clean
but he'll be here like shortly after
in the new year when everything gets
better
the next essential this one's very
important to me
lights my christmas lights
oh my god i have these up pretty much
all year long because
i don't know what it is about me but the
joy
that lights give me is outstanding i
think there's a crazy science to it
because
when i see them i cry like when i was
proposed to by my husband we went to
this
it was like on my birthday again and it
was christmas time
so we went to this place that decorated
the whole place with a lot of lights and
it was like i was a princess
i was like this is what it feels like to
be a princess in my photo shoot for my
album i literally did
this and was like and that was my one
request i was like i just want to be
smothered in lights
if i could have these all over my
clothes every day i would i even bought
earrings that light up like this
so cool i have a lot of a lot of lights
slides everyone makes fun of me if they
know the only gift i want is something
that lights up okay this is a big one
decorations are so essential this is a
must
as you see i have one here fun fact sad
fact
my obsession with online shopping got a
little too
we went a little too far with this so i
don't read all the details i say get it
i need it now
i thought these were little ornaments
that go on your tree
so i bought four of these and they're
all out throughout my house
and i was like god they're expensive but
maybe they're handcrafted
by some lady in her home turns out
they're just ginormous
but it's awesome so i'm not even mad i
was like oh great
this essential is very important to me
all year long but especially around the
holiday season
when i get a little crazy and order
crazy stuff online
hand it over oh it's my husband
so daryl he's so smart
with shopping we have a lot of family
members i kind of threw him into the
biggest family ever so he's been helping
me
get presents all year long and i'm
a spoiler i spoil people i love to spoil
people
yeah too much we're gonna get better and
we got a baby coming
so we're not gonna spoil you we're gonna
graze you right
as much as he can daryl keeps an eye out
when i have the laptop
and says don't go crazy he's taking over
the throne
this year with um santa claus he's
requested to be santa which in my
household
is a big duty it's a big job that's
right that's the person
santa who passes out all the gifts and
you have to dress full santa or else you
don't get the job
i've been the elf the past couple years
and i've graduated he's like i'm a dad
now i'm allowed to be santa
so it's a big year for me to go
i'm so worried about it it's the hard
job thank you so much for being my
essential
christmas but most importantly the
holidays in general
are so important to me it's like we get
to stop the world for a minute and we
get to be with our families
it's a great excuse to shut everything
down and just focus on
your loved ones and this year will be a
little different because we'll have to
zoom in with some loved ones this year
i'll be
ginormous so i'll probably be over it by
like 7 p.m
and next year is gonna be even more
important because i'll have a baby
and i'm gonna dress him up he's gonna be
so cute he's gonna be a reindeer
thank you so much thank you for watching
my top 10 essentials for the holidays
if you out there are like god i need a
new christmas album
i got it for you it's called a very
train of christmas it's out right now
check it out wherever you want it's
available stay safe
and give your family a hug for me and i
love ya